foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the video shoot of Our Song
baby don't hurt me
[Music]
to be here on the set today describe the
vibe how's everything going so far
well she didn't sleep she just arrived
from the UK and I'm very grateful how
long ago how much sleep are we running
on
um maybe four hours and
shoes
[Music]
I want to know the origin story of this
song you get this sample what makes you
think I gotta get Anne-Marie on this
track I'm just coming out of I'm good
and yeah it's like a sampling in in that
era I haven't sampled so much in my
career so this is like a new exercise
and it's a lot of fun it was great job
Anne Marie and her killer voice on the
record and then curly Ray she's still
getting ready for the video I'm sorry we
love of you koi we hope you make it in
this interview yeah but you know uh she
she's she's amazing it's really nice to
have so many influences on the same
record it's cool so I'm curious the song
David finishes it he sends it to you
what was your first reaction was it like
I must be a part of this it's very rare
where I do a collaboration I haven't
written the song yeah I heard this one
and I was like first of all it's an old
classic Banger yes yes and I was just
like and the verse also was written by
Ed Sheeran yeah which helps it makes me
want to dance and it makes me happy
[Music]
everybody
you're in perfect clothing to hit that
dance floor yeah are you guys gonna be
dancing in this video talk to me a
little bit about what we're gonna see
who's trying we're practicing we had a
special trainer for the for the Moon
is on fire
brings up memories of the iconic film A
Night at the Roxbury can you tell me if
yes back to that will this video have
little nods or touches to that
absolutely yeah underground parties a
little bit of a Fight Club too so that's
why we have the boxing ring everything
that has a little bit to do with
subculture I always love you walk me
through these looks can you tell me if
you picked this out the hair feels very
90s inspired as well yeah I think to be
honest my style in general is kind of
90s I go back to that where whatever
they used to wear so I wear all that
stuff all the time so this is just my
normal Sainsbury's to the shop you know
get some grass groceries okay this is
what I wait for you yeah
and me I just saw the 100 kilos of Coke
in Miami
and I just bought the kids
I was watching Miami Vice when I was
young and I loved it it made me feel
like okay let's go even 10 years younger
and then what is love you know
you just did Miami Vice because the song
premiered during your set at Ultra in
Miami yes yes that was so much fun we
both
we were like wow this is crazy they were
nuts and collaboration she killed it too
you know so uh she was very very happy
and very excited and hopefully she's
gonna be ready soon and she can come say
yeah say goodbye away here she is
what has this experience been like so
far on set
experience has been amazing this video
is going to be so dope to be able to
work with these amazing people here
these are icons you guys are so talented
and I'm so inspired by both of you so
it's a pleasure to be here right now
what are we gonna see you do in this
music video dancing are you serving
we're just giving looks we're going up
and yeah we're just giving looks we're
going crazy like always yes I love it
how Coy does it yes let's turn it up
Brian roll playback let's go
[Music]
how do you hope people feel when they
hear this song I feel like sexy
especially
I'm ready for the dirt again like oh my
God that's my favorite part
[Music]
I'm like I love my birth but that's my
video I don't and yeah I don't know if I
encourage you sorry yeah I don't care
and um yeah this video is gonna be
sickening we're about to kill it
[Music]
[Applause]